[Musique]
en sortant de l'école
bonjour sabrina non non non bonjour
bonjour je lis comme comment allez vous
non non comment arrêter comment attitude
bon tiens oui c'est franchement tu y
fait froid non enfin dont il fait chaud
m'écoute je crois que la lutte va être
très très serré puis du marché j'ai un
petit peu le trac
tu sais qu'il ya trois presque oui je
sais monsieur du fna est le facteur
monsieur les snobs voilà voilà voilà
j'en ai très peur de monsieur du
stockage est tellement cultiver monsieur
j'espère que je suis certain qu'il a
choisi un très joli poème emile
conspirent dû parfois même fait choisi
moi on va moi j'ai choisi un rapport à
bonn de jacques prévert fomina les
feuilles mortes se ramassent est très
jeune et mon poème s'appelle en sortant
de l'école
oh mais c'est formidable tu vas gagner
certainement avec ses mines à mettre ses
mails entrants pour moi dans la
littérature française et il ya beaucoup
d'autres très beau poème il ne
t'inquiète pas de toute façon c'est un
concours amical mais je sais
amy bon choix parler aux vainqueurs du
concours de poèmes tu vois ce que je
t'avais dit il certaines m'ont choisi un
peu un extraordinaire bonjour messieurs
du snob
vous avez l'air bien sûr de vous quel
point tu arrives au choisi le plus grand
victor hugo lamartine
je plaisantais je pense aragon même les
menus fretins que tout cela mais qui
alla le jeune alphonse du ce noble pour
vos services
antoine de nous qu'y at il d'étonnant à
cela
dans ce cas le règlement de la paire dit
pas bonjour à tous
ça va être un beau concours pas vrai oui
nous l'espérons tous l'acteur a pour sûr
en tout cas je vous ai réservé une belle
surprise
j'ai écris moi même mon poème c'est
original paraît pas totalement facteurs
baissiers du snob en a fait autant j'ai
une grande nouvelle
casimir tu écris ton pour toi même mais
mais comment savez vous eh bien monsieur
des snobs et le facteur on en fait
autant il est temps maintenant comment
vivaient nos enfants on va être le jury
les enfants aller avec julie aller mais
l'installation de leurs premiers
concurrents
monsieur emile campagne je suis un bon
facteur carter qui porte les colis ligne
je les livre à toute heure du jour et de
la nuit
j'ai besoin de courage rage rage s'il
faut que je me presse brice presse je
fais
de grands voyages ya un je garde pour
une lettre express espace car on voit
que c'est moi le meilleur des facteurs
pas vrai monsieur alphonse un gène du
snav un poème de ma composition dédiée à
moi demain je voudrais exprimer ce soir
le grand souci que j'ai de voir comment
la vie se passe ici vous avez remarqué
souci ici
quelles qualités de rim et puis ce sont
des verts de 12 pieds d alexandre france
continue notre île est en danger que nul
ne se dérobe
mais qui veut la sauver je le veux moi
disent non ici tout est mépris tout est
méchant celui pour les gens comme moi
les gens de qualité et je le dis bien
aurais je le dis sans rire je suis
meilleur poète que ne l'est quasiment
fini de s'amuser fini de se distraire
désormais il ne faut pas parler que de
grammaire et puis pour l'avenir mois 19
je propose que l'on ne parle plus ni
envers niveau du snob vous savez bien
qu'on ne parle qu'en vers ou en prose
vous avez fait la même bêtise que
monsieur jourdain dans le bourgeois
gentilhomme de molière c'est vrai voyage
la tête je vais rectifier ce dernier
deux derniers concurrents
casini
hier chez moi bon moi mon poème
s'intitule arrivée d'une moto dans une
basse-cour coin coin coin coin coin coin
coin point qu'elle capte peut-être
québec
tap tap tap à connaître au bout du parc
à 34 4 4 quoi parfaitement attaque
beaucoup au goût du public look loupe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les meilleurs dessins des scandales ne
resterai pas une seconde à vendredi
pour sûr le meilleur a gagné eh oui
casimir vainqueur rencontrera françois
pour la grande finale de poésie